the masked dancer has unmasked the ice
cube
[Music]
hello mr ice cube uh greetings
you know i am i am cool why did you
decide that you wanted to do the masked
dancer now well anytime i get a chance
to dance
i mean i'm in did dancing with the stars
birth that in you or did you just love
dancing before you even did that
yes i did i loved dancing my parents
were
both very good ballroom dancers i just
got hooked on it i think it's great
when you're unmasked what is that like
when they're all saying take it off take
it off
well you know i hear that so often uh
but
this was this was in the context of the
masked dancer yeah it was
it's a relief but it's also dog got it
i got found out the night was also a
roller coaster for cotton candy
she fell nearly head first while
rehearsing this ambitious aerial routine
were you nervous at all no there's an
ancient saying in the theta
if you don't get nervous stop doing it
michelle i am of a certain age
really what age is that bill
i'm old enough to get vaccinated
some of the moves are really quick yeah
they were quick i had a great time